Stargate is trending on Twitter at
number one again
when are they gonna listen welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
so this video isn't going to have
anything particularly new in it it's
just going to be me ranting but
I'm ranting because this is the greatest
show on television we literally just did
a live stream and we decided our top
five sci-fi shows of all time and
Stargate sg1 was voted by us as number
one and I know by a lot of you so why is
Stargate a show that SGU remember
finished in 2011 so this is a show a
franchise that hasn't even been on our
screens for 12 years why is it trending
number one for sci-fi and television on
Twitter
because we desperately want this show to
return Hollywood Amazon you keep
remaking all of these TV shows we keep
doing videos on this channel every damn
week about new Sci-Fi reboot
we get news almost every day of another
reboot
will bring back a show that we actually
want to see
Stargate sg1 Stargate Atlantis Target
Universe were in their own rights unique
and excellent television shows they
brought a humor and characters into our
lives that we
really really miss now if you are a
regular site tracker you'll know that
loads and loads of work is being done
bringing us closer and closer to a new
Stargate series we know that Mark Fergus
and Hawk ospies penguin and Parker TV
show pitched for the new series I'm
actually Mark Fergus actually asked
Amazon if he could make the show
we know that they are talking to other
production companies now and I'm hearing
rumors that there's even a relationship
potentially between original pictures
and Sony pictures about towards making a
new Stargate franchise movies and TV
and we know that there are enough people
out there that still love this show that
go on Twitter and other social media
platforms like Facebook every single day
talking about Stargate we have people
that tweet every single day different
memes different scenes different bits of
information about Stargate I follow
almost all of them we've had several
Twitter storms we want Stargate bring
back Stargate and we keep shouting it as
loud as we can I am going to keep making
videos like this until they bloody
listen
Amazon you have the sleeping giant of
sci-fi on your hands you have one of the
greatest TV shows ever made you could
actually do prequels that make sense by
doing some sort of ancients TV series
you could do series on lots of different
worlds the possibilities are literally
endless
so why don't you do it now I know you
are pinching the pennies at the moment I
know you don't have as much money as you
once did I know the streaming laws are
coming to an end because you've all kind
of lost and spent way too much money
but this is a franchise that is a
no-brainer it's easy so just do it now
I'm now talking to people that work in
and around Amazon that when they were
trying to buy MGM that Stargate was
brought up repeatedly
so
stop trying to overthink this just do a
simple TV show that we can all enjoy get
Brad Wright involved he has an idea how
to move forwards bring him on as a
consultant we don't care he won't care
just get him on board
get Mark Ferguson hall Coast be on this
now
get them paid get them contracted get a
production company and like original
film or somebody else that can make the
show and just crack on and get it done
if you want to do a movie first fine do
a movie first we don't really care about
that either just get on with it
guys if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
also share this ranting video wherever
the hell you want because the more we
talk about it the more we go on Twitter
and we talk about it the more Amazon
will listen and eventually Amazon will
actually pull the trigger and we will
get the show and the movies that we
really want if you also want to support
the channel and you really want to
become a fully fledged side tracker
don't forget about hitting that join
button and as always please stay safe
I'll see you next time I suppose now is
the time for me to say something
profound
[Music]
nothing comes to mind let's do it